there was a new kid on the portable
gaming block and
one of us has played it that person is
of course giant bomb's
very own jan ochoa jan how you doing
good good sir thank you for having me of
course uh always happy to be talking
games with you so you went down
to valve headquarters and managed to get
you some hands on time
with this steam deck first of all yes
how how was it like
first impressions of it uh initial
impressions uh the unit is absolutely
huge
we brought over a couple of consoles to
compare size with we brought over a
nintendo switch
uh gba a ps vita and a game gear because
you know you need to bring your props um
and it was it was much bigger
than all of those and i think that was
like an initial thing that a lot of
people were worried about
when they initially announced the steam
deck but
it is a big unit but it is surprisingly
very very light and it feels good to
hold i don't know if you run into this
tam uh with holding
like a nintendo switch when it's in
handhold mode but my hands get really
fatigued because
there's no real like good place to grip
your hands kind of like flat like this
but with the steam deck the edges where
the buns are
it's a little bit curved so it feels
much more comfortable to hold
for an extended period of time it's very
light which was surprising because i i
was thinking it'd be
something super duper heavy but maybe
that's just like my own brain being
poisoned with having to stick like six
double a's into like a game gear
or something um but yeah i it was it was
really really neat
you know right i guess like my first
question
around the so you said it's light and
your hands didn't really get fatigued
how long were you kind of playing it for
and do you think that
given that you know the battery life can
range from anywhere between four to
eight hours
that fatigue might still set in or do
you feel like you could comfortably hold
a beefy
handheld like that for an extended
gaming session i don't think you could
hold
the beefy steam deck over your head
laying down for an extended period of
time i think either way you may feel
fatigued enough that you might drop it
on your face
but if you're just sitting down on a
couch and like casually playing in front
of you or you're commuting
um i think i think you'd have an okay
enough time
i should say an ad that the units we had
the demo with
aren't final they'd actually just gone
the units the day before we had arrived
so a lot of stuff still up in the air um
but speaking about the battery life if
you pl
unplug the unit from a power source the
uh overall
power of the unit isn't supposed to
change you're supposed to get the same
experience whether or not you're playing
hardwired plugged into power or you're
just running off the battery
i should add also that rory and i matt
rory from giantbomb also
we kept switching between a bunch of
games and we had the brightness jacked
all the way up as well as the audio so
that was probably affecting
the overall battery life for about maybe
like an hour and a half
running off of just battery constantly
switching between things
and not like doing a quick resume type
of thing just fully shutting down a game
and
waiting for something else to load up uh
the battery may have drained to maybe
30 35 rory didn't seem to have
that much fatigue he was playing a
straight more than i was
i guess one of the other things in terms
of ergonomics is
a lot of people have been looking at the
two sticks
at the very top of the device how was
that and also the curved button on the
side
how was it to hold and stretch your
thumbs up all the way and did you have
any issues where you were
because it's got the sticks it's got the
buttons and then it's got the touch pads
underneath um yeah any like crossover
there any issues with pr
playing it did you find the touch pads
to be useful
so unfortunately we didn't come across
any games that utilized the touchpads
that well
we tried disco elysium and you know
that's a point and click adventure type
of game so we were thinking
uh we'd be able to use the touch pads
but in that current build
um it wasn't optimized for that they
were i think
using how the control scheme that it is
on
playstation so uh it's relying more on
the analog sticks than touch pads
it felt very similar to holding a wii u
tablet
where the analog sticks are kind of
jacked all the way up it took some
getting used to
we fired up hades and hades you know
it's kind of burned into your
muscle memory if you've beaten the game
a couple times
and it took a little bit of time to
get acclimated to aiming and like
running around in it
but after a while like it i it didn't
feel too weird having the analog sticks
like
that far up on the unit um having your
hands rested in neutral they'd
be your thumbs would probably be on the
touch pads and even then
depending on whatever game you'd be
playing that could utilize them more
effectively i think it'd be okay
we we fired up doom eternal and rory was
having
uh a normal time playing through that
game uh we fired up
sea of thieves and you know just jump
literally jumping around
in the game i didn't feel any issues or
anything different and again it's just
like
getting your hands used to the uh
placement but the steam deck does have
the options to
turn off the paddles in the back it does
have paddles like a
an elite controller would i think you
can also turn off the touch pads uh
depending on the game by game basis
so there's just three models of the the
steam deck and
the main distinguishing features between
the cheaper model and the two the
mid-range and the high price range one
is the
um the lower end one has emmc uh
storage while the other one has nvme ssd
storage
do you know which model you're playing
and what kind what was it what was the
experience of like loading and switching
between games like for you
um i'm not 100 sure which model they had
us demo
but given our demo time with the unit
i think i would stray closer to at least
the mid-tier
option rather than the uh the
entry-level one with
like the 64 gig sd card i mean you can
slap in a different sd card of course
but the loading times i would assume uh
would be much better
not with uh the entry level unit
the baseline one um low times you know
for the most part
it it it was it was pretty good you know
we
we actually did a comparison run test uh
trying to load up hades on inside of
switch versus the steam deck
uh the steam deck had to run through its
initial os stuff
uh but then it wound up eclipsing it um
while the switch was still loading into
hades we ran the test again
except instead of trying to load into
hades we loaded into control
and then it like mid way while the
switch was still loading
into hades the steam deck had already
loaded into control and is ready at the
main menu
um yeah yeah i will say there
were a couple hitches in control i don't
know if that was because
you know there's still a pre-production
unit it isn't completely final
but we were actually because you know
it's it's
pretty much a pc in your hands we were
able to bump down
the um the video settings and we're
actually able to get a smoother 60
fps right right and and
the you mentioned that it is basically a
pc in your hands did you
get to do anything with the non-gaming
application
side of it like were you loading up like
fruity loops on there or anything like
what's going on
uh not fruity loops i wasn't able to get
my uh
producer mode uh up in seattle
but they did have a demo unit where they
had the steam deck
set up in like a desktop environment and
that was
it has a usbc port on top and they had
it going out to a usb
hub and then from the hub going an hdmi
out there
and a bluetooth mouse and keyboard and
this was the most surprising thing to me
because it was running
it had like a vlc playback going on loop
some coding instance going on uh it also
had blender going which is like a 3d
modeling software and it was also
running netflix
and factorio at the same time which was
super impressive
and there wasn't anything extra going on
it was just docked so you know you had
an ability with keyboard to do a little
bit more um
and that was super impressive because
you know a lot of people say that this
is like the nintendo switch killer but
upon having my actual own actual time
with it and just seeing how the devs are
approaching this machine
i don't think that way at all anymore
it's more so
getting people into the pc
sphere right getting them into the steam
ecosystem
and you know you mentioned fruity loops
they're super open about
how open the steam deck
can be they weren't shying around away
from like
yeah you know like you could probably
install xyz onto it
we're not gonna tell you how or if you
could do that but you
you have the ability to do so so you
know it feels super
like it will be super open where you
could install fruity loops
you could probably i don't know install
adobe premiere
and be editing with a controller you
know
which would be a nightmare but kind of
neat
well there's there's an idea for your
next video on a giant bomb or maybe
maybe we'll do it over here
or something thank you so much for
giving us your overall impressions um
obviously there's way more to the
experience of playing the
uh steam deck but i would encourage
everyone to head to giantbomb.com
there's a video on the site and also on
youtube where
jan and rory are hanging out and talking
about playing uh
their experience of it and it goes into
in-depth uh about
what they kind of feel about it which is
very very good keep an eye on
youtube.com four slash games but we'll
have plenty more
um discussion about the steam deck as we
get closer to the
release and also we'll probably throw in
some game gear chat as well because you
know
oh why not i've been ready let's go
i need to find the game here the tv
tuner
yeah jen thank you so much for your time
thank you tim